hey guys I'm out of the country but we
didn't want to leave you hanging with no
good news so here's something positive
that happened
starting in 2024 films
will be required to meet new inclusion
standards
to be eligible for the Academy Awards
for Best Picture
they'll have to have a certain
percentage of actors or crew from
underrepresented racial and ethnic
groups
what do you think of these new inclusion
standards for films they make me vomit
why
because
this is an art form
it's also a form of Commerce and it
makes money but it's an art
and no one should be telling me as an
artist
that I have to give in to the latest
most current idea of what morality is
and what are we risking are we really
risking hurting people's feelings
you can't legislate that
and
you have to let life be life and I'm
sorry I don't think that there's a
minority or a majority in the country
that has to be catered to like that
you know Lawrence Olivier
was the last white actor to play Othello
and he did it in 1965 and he did it in
blackface
and he played a black man
brilliantly
am I being told that I will never have a
chance
to play a black man
is someone else being told that if
they're not Jewish they shouldn't play
The Merchant of Venice
are we crazy
do we not know that art is art
this is so patronizing it's so it's so
Thoughtless and and treating people like
children
foreign